restaurant ria pizza il ne reste que cet
enchevêtrement de poutre métallique et
de béton plus une fenêtre plus une porte
l'établissement a complètement été
soufflé le choc est tel que les
bâtiments aux alentours sont largement
endommagés et les voitures on les vitres
brisés
elle est vraiment dans un sale état
à ma voiture
beaucoup sont en état de choc
ou en pleurs
l'attaque a eu lieu vers 20h heure
locale en plein air de pointe donc dans
un restaurant populaire très fréquenté
par les journalistes et les militaires
qui ont tous les quatre assis dans un
restaurant
plus rien et il y a du sang partout du
verre des gens dans la rue
même des enfants avec du sang
il y avait beaucoup de monde
selon la police ukrainienne il s'agirait
de deux roquettes russes les S300 très
performants et très actifs depuis le
début du conflit le bilan est déjà très
lourd principalement des civils la
Russie dément pourtant viser des sites
civils depuis le début de la guerre
dans la soirée la solidarité s'est
organisée une chaîne humaine pour
déblayer les gravats et pour permettre
au secouriste de sortir de potentiels
survivants
ce n'est pas la première fois que cette
grande ville de loblaste de denietzk est
prise pour cible en avril 2022 la gare
ferroviaire de kramatorzek avait été
bombardé bilan 63 morts
voilà pour cette soirée d'Hor